so what we're facing is potentially AI
systems that are smarter than any human
at doing a wide range of things but also
that are potentially a hundred a
thousand maybe a hundred thousand times
faster than humans I think when we
confront very fast powerful general
purpose AI systems that's the kind of
situation we're going to be in we're
going to be out class not just in terms
of intelligence but also reaction speed
why are you as an evolutionary
psychologist researcher talking about AI
I just love getting into trouble and
making making trouble on Twitter
no I actually look
long story short when I started uh my
PhD program at Stanford in way back in
1987 right I was studying cognitive
psychology and cognitive science and
pretty quickly uh we got one of the
leading neural networks uh researchers
at Stanford psychology a guy named David
rummelhart who worked very extensively
with Jeffrey Hinton and lots of other
people
um and so I started in grad school doing
a lot of work on neural networks and
machine learning and genetic algorithms
and so forth and then I spent
um most of my postdoctoral years at
University of Sussex also in a cognitive
science department doing autonomous
robots and sort of applying genetic
algorithms to evolve neural networks so
a long time ago I was sort of an early
adopter of machine learning
and then I got sidetracked into this
evolutionary psychology thing you know
for about 30 years
recently
um
since about 2016 I've I've become
concerned and fascinated by rapid
progress in in AI particularly deep
learning and the large language models
and I sort of fell in with this gaggle
of effective altruists right this
movement who we're quite concerned about
uh existential risks risks to all of
humanity and a lot of them were very
concerned about how AI could play out so
uh the last few years I've been reading
a lot about this since last summer I've
been publishing a bunch of essays on the
effect of altruism forum and gotten
pretty active on Twitter uh the last few
months about AI X risk so to to the
Casual Observer right they might go well
who is this psychology dude suddenly
interested in AI
well honestly I've been fascinated by AI
ever since I was a high schooler reading
science fiction you know and ever since
grad school learning about cognitive
science
so that's my long story short that
wasn't actually very short is it right
to say that most of the researchers in
the existential risk world c a i as one
of the if not the Premier Primary risk
that we're facing
yeah absolutely there's a great book by
Toby ORD ORD who's an Oxford moral
philosopher but he has worked a lot on
existential risks so he did a book
called The precipice
right and he actually tries to quantify
the different Extinction risks that we
Face some of them are really really low
probability but really hard to fight
like if there's a local gamma-ray
burster right or uh a supernova very
very low likelihood very hard to defend
against other stuff like asteroids right
which get a lot of attention very very
low likelihood like there's probably
less than a one in a million chance
we're going to get a dangerous asteroid
in The Next Century if it comes that
could be bad but you know there's stuff
we can do about it
whereas uh topiord estimates estimates
that the risk of Extinction human
extinction through AI in this century is
about one in six and I think that's sort
of in line with a lot of the estimates
that many experts give the other the
other big risks are basically nuclear
war
which is still an issue right after you
know 70 years of thermonuclear weapons
being around so nuclear war
possibly genetically engineered bio
weapons could be really bad it would be
like covet on steroids that could wipe
out a lot of people
but uh the other the other one is AI so
those seem to be the big three AI nukes
and super germs
yeah it's an interesting one man I
remember that uh sheet that chart that
he has it's burned into my memory it's
one of the five books that I think
everybody should read in my reading list
that I've sent to a million people it's
one of the five books that I think
everybody should read if you want a
primer on extra risk the prespace is the
place to start and yeah one in six
chance that Humanity goes extinct within
the next 100 years
due to Ai and I think that the word the
precipice is about a squeezed bottleneck
a treacherous path Beyond which there
could be this sort of Glorious future uh
but right now there is a very particular
very important forced function for
we don't know how long it could continue
but it's definitely we're definitely not
far off it at the moment
yeah the way I visualize it I like the
precipice metaphor that it's this Narrow
Path sort of up a mountain but if you've
ever seen the movie free solo about uh
what's his name Alex honol climbing up
half dome right I almost think of it as
like we've been doing a walk through the
woods
as humans for like the last 200 000
years and the the level of risk we face
is relatively low and suddenly we're
climbing up Half Dome without ropes or
pitons or any safety gear
and if we can just kind of make it to
the top
then I think we'll be you know at a
relatively lower risk state
hopefully in several decades
um but a lot of people in the effect of
altruism movement think this is what
they call a key Century a time of
particularly High elevated risk when
Humanity has to be extra extra careful
and smart and risk-averse and very very
self-aware about what we're doing
okay so lay out the landscape of AI risk
why is it something that we should be
concerned about how have we got
ourselves here what's changed over time
I think the basic
intuition that lots of people are
developing now
is that
there are gradations of intelligence in
the natural world right squirrels are
smarter than squid
um monkeys are smarter than squirrels
we're smarter than monkeys
but we are not the ultimate level of
intelligence
we can easily surpass uh human reasoning
and planning abilities in lots of ways
and in fact right everybody on their
smartphone already has apps that are
better at doing certain narrow things
than we ever could like Google Maps is
better at figuring out where to go than
I would be with paper map
um face recognition right is way better
than than I am at face recognition I'm
I've got a little bit of postpagnosia
like recognizing people you know like at
the the human behavior and evolution
Society conference we're both at two
weeks ago it's a little challenging for
me uh computer vision systems have
gotten very good at it
so one issue is
we are approaching the point where AI
systems are getting more and more
general purpose and smarter and smarter
across many many different domains
and that represents a kind of major
evolutionary transition in intelligence
where we could be outclassed
a second thing that I worry a lot more
about than some people seem to is just
the raw speed issue
right if anybody's played around with
chat GPT
right and you've asked it to write a
little essay or an outline or any kind
of language you know oh my God it is so
fast is a way faster at writing material
than humans could be
and it's not even particularly optimized
to be fast in that way
so what we're facing is potentially
AI systems that are smarter than any
human doing a wide range of things
but also that are potentially a hundred
a thousand maybe a hundred thousand
times faster
than humans
and the way I like to think about that
is you know you might be familiar with
the uh the Speedster superheroes like
the Flash
right or Quicksilver where once they do
their kind of super speed and they're
running around it's as if everybody else
is just Frozen in place
I think when we confront
um very fast powerful general purpose AI
systems
that's the kind of situation we're going
to be in we're going to be out class not
just in terms of intelligence but also
reaction speed
right you could potentially have an AI
trading bot right that's trading
equities or crypto or whatever just way
way faster than any human can follow
um you could have military AI
applications
right that can kind of simulate
scenarios in terms of
um tactical applications or firefights
where they can kind of run through like
every possible way
that they could engage with an enemy
um
and kind of spin spin out these these
simulations and then just completely
outclass an opponent in terms of tactics
and strategy
so I think these two things right as
being smarter potentially and also
extremely fast
um it takes a while for the full
implications of that to sink in but I
think they're kind of worrying well
let's think about uh JCB Digger right
it's larger and stronger than a human
but it is a tool that is under our
Command so why should we be concerned
about an AI which is faster and smarter
than us it just makes us do things
quicker and better than we would have
known how to do it surely
yeah if we're just Outsourcing
you know suggestions to the AI like with
Google Maps we're saying how do I get
from A to B right and Google Maps is not
actually taking control of our Tesla
it's not driving for us we're not
Outsourcing our agency right that's
relatively safe
right the AI could still manipulate Us
in lots of ways it could nudge our
decisions in certain directions for its
own ends or for the the interests of
somebody else like the people who
developed AI
but once you give it agency once you
Outsource decision-making powers
that's where I think the real danger
starts to come in
so for example you know there's a big
difference between
uh like a military AI that has the
ability to suggest
certain courses of action like steer
this carrier Strike Force towards this
ocean for this purpose right versus an
AI that actually has control and
decision making uh power over like okay
it's time to launch a bunch of f-35s to
go bomb this country
the trouble is because of the huge speed
advantage of AI there will be very very
strong incentives to give it agency
right to make it able to make decisions
in a sort of
reception decision action Loop that's
like way faster than a human could do
um there will be commercial incentives
to do that if you're in any kind of
competitive environment like
um Finance or military applications or
even uh you know market research
so that you can do
um
optimization of some you know anything
you want to optimize
um better by by sort of Outsourcing some
agency to the AI
that was a little vague but if if that
made sense let me it does but as of yet
you haven't talked about artificial
general intelligence or some Terminator
Arnold Schwarzenegger apocalypse or
becoming
self-aware recursive self-improvement
machine extrapolated volition I haven't
heard any of that so presumably in
between now and a concern that I think
was very prevalent maybe a decade ago or
so when Toby or Nick boss from Super
intelligence book came out which was
that once you reached Singularity
there's going to be all of these
problems it seems like there's some
pretty dangerous gradations between now
and there so what what's happened in the
world of AI risk concern over the last
decade in terms of how that was a
problem it's changed and then what what
are the gradations between now and where
we could get to in future
yeah so when Nick Bostrom and Oxford
philosopher uh published super
intelligence which is a great book
another must read it's a little
technical it's challenging don't try and
read it okay yeah that was 2013.
Bostrom emphasized very heavily the
notion of like
a self-improving takeoff where like an
AI could get pretty smart and then it
starts optimizing its own software and
potentially hardware and then you get a
kind of
um explosion of capabilities
that could potentially happen very very
quickly like the AI could sort of go
from like
human level level intelligence to
super intelligence that's smarter than
all humans who have ever lived in a
matter of perhaps
days or weeks or months
now that's a super scary scenario I
think it's legit to worry about it I
take a slightly different View and I
think a lot of people are also taking a
different view that even fairly narrow
AI That's like not even as smart as
humans in many ways could still be
extremely dangerous for example
if you have a narrow AI that is very
very good at designing bio weapons
right and doing kind of gain of function
research through computer simulating
here's how a virus could spread through
the world you could have like a bio
weapon narrow AI
that actually invents an extremely
um dangerous pandemic right and you
might think nobody's sane would want to
do that well there are lots of insane
people in the world there's lots of
nihilists and terrorists and and you
know drothers and people who don't like
human civilization who might be
motivated to use that kind of narrow AI
you can also have narrow AI applications
that could be very politically
destabilizing you know you could have
extremely good video deep fake
technology that makes it look as if
Vladimir Putin or Xi Jinping or or Joe
Biden has declared war on some other
major nation state
and that provokes an extremely panicked
military response
right that could lead to like global
thermonuclear war
and we're not really very ready for that
kind of
thing and and that stuff could happen
you know within a couple years
like people debate when will we get
artificial general intelligence it could
be five years ten years 50 years who
knows but these narrow AI applications
are coming down the pike very very
quickly and they could be pretty
destabilizing
what has happened with the development
of neural networks and large learning
models that maybe caught a lot of AI
X risk safety alignment researchers
unawares and kind of how's that changed
the Viewpoint of concerns around AI
what we're basically seeing is very
rapid advances in Hardware
you know memory size and speed so when I
was doing neural network research back
in the late 80s right we were playing
around with networks that had like maybe
a few dozen maybe a few hundred units
and if maybe a few hundred or a few
thousand parameters meaning the weights
in the network that kind of connect
little simulated neurons together
so a few thousand parameters back then
now it's like trillions
of parameters in the large language
models because the hardware is just
better right we we can make GPU chips
that are much much more powerful and
once you get to a certain
size of network with enough
hidden layers learning using the Deep
learning methods
you get kind of powerful emergent
properties popping out
that nobody was really quite prepared
for and that's where we've been
blindsided by chat GPT what like
just like people kind of thought well if
if you make these large language models
kind of predict like the next language
token and you feed them a lot of
information about the whole content of
the internet
um then maybe they might be able to
answer some basic questions
right it's kind of like a Google search
but lo and behold they're way more
powerful than people expected
right like you can
ask chatgpt to do all kinds of things
that really wasn't designed to do that
people didn't kind of grow it to do like
write an outline for a screenplay
um figure out uh how to write a summary
of AI existential risks GPT is pretty
good at that in a kind of self-recursive
way
um it can do math it can do computer
programming it can do an awful lot of
capabilities that people
really they thought like maybe that's 10
or 20 years away and boom here it is in
available to everybody available to 100
million users of chat GPT so that's
where the shock has come that once you
get to
you know a multi-trillion parameter
large language model
man it's looking pretty close
to artificial general intelligence it's
not quite there yet and it's still
fallible and there's still a lot it
can't do but
you know if you if you had a time
machine
and you took chat GPT back in a laptop
to 10 years ago in 2013.
and you ask people does this look like
um
artificial general intelligence they go
holy moly yeah that's pretty effing
close that's
way more advanced than we expected it
would be by 2023 so that's the concern
like
the fact that you can be so surprised
by the pace of development means maybe
the next step whatever that is is going
to Blindside us as much or even more and
this is the same group of people who
said it's one in six as the chance that
Humanity goes extinct due to AI within
the next Century so you
I don't think by anybody's standards
that would be considered a conservative
estimate it sounds crazy you know you're
rolling a dice and on one side is a
button that destroys Humanity so
you know again just that that's quite a
stock claim I guess yeah one in six is
literally Russian Roulette
so if you're playing Russian roulette
and and the head is not like a single
individual's head but your whole species
that's that's what you're doing
so what is the definition of AGI and why
doesn't chat GPT yet
breach it
Atri means artificial general
intelligence and the way that the
research groups themselves like deepmind
and open Ai and anthropic the way they
Define it is basically an AI system that
can do
um
just about everything a human can do
in terms of cognition and perception to
about the standard that a professional
would do it in a job right so with an
AGI
you should be able to train it to be as
good at medical diagnosis as a doctor or
as good at teaching a class as as I am
as a professor as good at playing chess
as a chess Grandmaster as good at
training trading equities as a good Wall
Street Trader and everything else right
and the real power comes from the fact
that once you have an AGI
that can do all of that that's fairly
general purpose you can copy it
right you can copy it and you can make
one copy of it do one human job another
copy do another human job
and then they could potentially even
trade information about how you how you
do this
so
you know the explicit goal of open Ai
and it's it's ceosm Altman is create
AGI as fast as possible and make it so
it can automate most human jobs
as as fast as possible
so that raises lots of issues about
unemployment
but it also raises lots of issues about
existential risk
because among the many jobs right that
an AGI could learn to do would be like
be a really good terrorist at making
bombs be a really good military
strategist in terms of overcoming Russia
or China or America be a really good spy
be really good propagandist who can
shape the outcome of Elections
Etc so the the point of AGI is it should
be able to do anything people can do
about as well as people can do it and
that includes not just all the good
stuff
right like being a good veterinarian who
fixes dogs or being a good nurse who
takes care of people with psychiatric
disorders it also means all the bad
stuff
that bad people can do
what do you think of Sam Altman
I think he's a brilliant guy and I think
he has
what to him is a compelling vision of
the future
and I think he genuinely believes that
developing AGI will lead to a kind of
awesome human Utopia
he talks
as if he understands the extinction
risks
but I don't I think there's some deep
deep cognitive dissonance right because
on the one hand
if he really took the extinction risks
seriously
I think
he would shut down open AI they would no
longer do research they would say this
is radioactive this is toxic this is
crazy this is Russian Roulette let's not
do this
um and he's not doing that he's not
shutting it down he's sort of pushing
more or less full steam ahead and he's
making some little noises about we need
to be careful and we need to be you know
we need to get good regulation blah blah
but I don't think it's really a
heartfelt appreciation
of the kind of Toby ORD point that dude
you're talking about one in six at least
risk of human extinction this century
uh to most people in the world
that sounds absolutely insane
and Reckless and it's something we did
not consent to what do you say to the
people that would push back and say well
look Sam Altman at least he's fighting
for the good guys he's somebody that's
from the West the choices between us
getting there first or Russia getting
there first or China getting their first
this is a Winner Takes not only all but
takes the world and takes the world for
the rest of time and then you've got
potentials of uh bad social lock-in or
whatever it's called that William
mccaskill came up with we he's on the
side of the good guys if the good guys
don't win the bad guys win therefore we
need to make sure the good guys win
I think it's worth asking okay like
I'm American lots of Americans think we
are automatically the good guys by
definition anything America does is good
anything that a rival does is bad and we
must win at all costs one thing I would
say is you know if it's an arms race
into a concrete wall
it's not really a race you want to
engage in right it's kind of like a game
of chicken but where nobody can swerve
um I think if the likely outcome of the
arms race is
Extinction then
everybody who's contemplating the arms
race should try their best to avoid to
avoid getting caught up in it how are
you going to coordinate this are you
going to coordinate China and Russia to
get on board with your very loadable
altruistic desire to get some Altman to
just go to the Canary Islands for the
rest of his life without a laptop or an
internet connection
I think this the the traditional
approach to this right is What's called
the AI governance model where you get a
bunch of policy wonks and Washington DC
insiders and uh people in in the UK
government in Whitehall thinking really
hard about how to regulate AI so it's
benign and how to reduce the the arms
race Dynamics
and I think that's fine and that's a
good worthy thing to do unfortunately I
think it's way too slow
and it's way too easy for the AI
industry to to sort of capture what
happens in their own interests
um and honestly the politicians are
involved in this simply don't understand
AI well enough I think to have a very um
sensible way of of approaching this
issue
a second strategy which is something
I've been advocating uh recently is a
little more informal a little more
Grassroots and kind of bottom up
which is I think there's certain
industries
where it's okay to just look at them and
go
that's bad that's evil that's reckless
we should stigmatize
that industry we should stigmatize
everybody who works in that industry
who supplies anything necessary to that
industry who finances that industry and
it's just a bad industry and we want to
try to slow it down we have done that
with many many you know Industries in in
the past crypto has been handicapped
very very successfully by adverse PR and
moral stigmatization campaigns by
politicians and Central bankers and so
forth uh the arms industry right has
been heavily stigmatized there's lots of
ethical investment criteria for
investors that say things like hey let's
not invest in Alcohol Tobacco gambling
arms trading human trafficking Etc
right and I think
um at the moment
there's quite a bit of popular
opposition to the AI industry and
concerned about these risks and I think
we should kind of normalize
people being able to say I didn't vote
for this I don't support this I don't
want these Extinction risks imposed on
me and my kids and the people are doing
who are doing it
um should be stigmatized I suppose one
of the problems is that with
weapons or crypto or gain a function
research coming out of a BSL level 2 lab
or something that's not sufficiently
secure
people are able to observe
experience and imagine the problems
quite easily at the moment all that
they've found is a really cool way to
get them to write short essays or tell
them jokes for their best man speech so
as of yet the experience of AI
especially neural Nets and large
learning models has not
been
what you are concerned about moving
forward which means where is the
incentive for people to get on board
with this
yeah I think
there's an important role here for
um
imagination and fiction and scenario
building so remember when when people
were very worried about global
thermonuclear war like when I was in
college in the 80s this is all we talked
about and all we worried about is like
how long is it going to be till the US
and the Soviet Union have a massive
exchange of icbms and we all die
um we could visualize that stuff very
clearly because like Hollywood movies
and TV series did a pretty good job of
showing what that would look like none
of us had personal experience of
Hiroshima or Nagasaki right we kind of
read the accounts and it was it was
horrible but
um when you're trying to imagine
potential harms from new technology
all you really have to go on is sort of
what experts say the risks are and then
the way that that screenwriters and
directors uh visualize those risks in a
way that the the public can understand I
don't disagree the problem you have is
that you're not only trying no one has
ever said look at that atomic bomb it
gives me so much pleasure and it's so
cool no one has ever said the same thing
about an engineered pandemic but when it
comes to chat GPT and its iterations
Downstream people are finding benefits
in it in the now and they're trying to
be told you need to let go of this thing
which you see as a positive in order for
something which you can't foresee as a
negative
yeah and this is where I think it's
important for people to kind of tap into
their uh they're kind of I think
increasing sophistication that there can
be
very very seductive technologies that
can have very toxic kind of social side
effects even even that's you know the
discussion about social media itself
I think has moved from oh wow this is
cool we can connect with our
grandparents and we can find people to
date to
oh my God is this creating like Mass
mental illness in gen Z in a way that we
we really need to rethink how Tech talk
and Instagram and and so forth operate
so I think people have the ability to
understand
some new technology can be very
seductive
it can look great it's new and shiny but
you know there might be
um
kind of a viper hiding inside it that
could be pretty poisonous
um
the other thing I would I would add is
you know when I was I was teaching
online courses for Chinese University of
Hong Kong Shenzhen a couple years ago
and we talked quite a bit about AI
Extinction risks and this is a bunch of
Chinese undergrads in Shenzhen very
smart
they understand
existential risk they're tuned in to
nuclear war they understood bioweapons
because the covid pandemic was raging
and they think quite a bit about AI
right because China had said we want to
be the leading AI superpower by 2030.
that was their plan a few years ago
and these Chinese students were like
perfectly willing to understand the
risks and to stigmatize
AI
right they had a kind of moral
imperative and concern for the future of
of humanity those just as strong as what
my my American undergrads have so I
think we have this stereotype in the
West
that
um other countries like China are sort
of full of
um unthinking
automatons who have been programmed by
their government and their authoritarian
regime so that they will just do
whatever
you know Xi Jinping says but I think
actually there's quite a bit more room
for uh a kind of global Grassroots
opposition to AI not just in America and
Britain but also in other countries that
are kind of key um
you know potential arms race players
well
isn't China a country in which they've
refused to make public a lot of the
neural Nets and the developments in AI
unlike in America where citizens can
just go in and play around with it China
said well we can't be sure that this
thing isn't going to start telling
everyone about Tiananmen Square so
because we don't have control over it
we're not going to let it Loose with the
public which is it has to be curtailing
the development because it's not able to
do any of the learning that it would
have done had it have been iterated over
1.25 billion users all of whom are
asking it how to make a cake this
evening
yeah I think it's
it's very interesting because insofar as
the Chinese government really wants AI
mostly for purposes of of social control
and social stability and and censorship
and reducing crime and reducing
terrorism
right to have a much narrower range of
AI applications than your typical
American AI company wants right Chinese
government I think is is not really
interested in the kind of
techno utopian vision of like the
singularity and transhumanism and let's
all like upload our minds into the
Matrix the way that you see in a lot of
the Bay Area
AI enthusiasts right they're not really
into that they just want like China to
be stable and prosperous
um so here again what's happening I
think is the American AI companies are
at The Cutting Edge
right they're Far and Away more advanced
as far as we know than anything
happening in in China much less Russia
or Brazil or the UK
um and they're just kind of trying to
play catch-up
all right what's happening is like we're
far out in front in terms of the arms
race
if I was a Chinese uh policy expert
I would be freaking out I'd be wanting
to to play catch up I'd be very
concerned about AI having a kind of a
America having a kind of AI hegemony
and it would it would look like a threat
to me that I have to respond to
so we are setting the pace in terms of
the arms race if we slow down
right China might go whoo thank God like
we don't have the talent or the
resources to play this arms race
we can okay if America is relaxing we
can relax too
we can focus on other issues like no
how do you get Chinese people to have
kids and stuff like that right
um use AI
yeah
AI matchmaking right that might be a key
key application for them
so I think here again Americans have to
look in the mirror and go to what extent
are we really setting the pace with the
arms race are we forcing other countries
to try to catch up that's right maybe
maybe if we slow down
we can all you know take a step back
take a breath
pause think what what exactly are we
doing should we be playing this Russian
Roulette
yeah that's a very good point I hadn't I
hadn't considered I suppose as well that
the wake of what is on the internet and
what is available what is
um a public knowledge about what's
happening at all of these different
neural net companies will be
slipstreamed in some regard by Foreign
actors you know the the source was I
think a long time ago open sourced and
then it's no longer open sourced which
means that you can't fully see what's
going on side in terms of workings but
I'm sure that you can determine a good
amount of stuff or at least a
non-insignificant amount of stuff from
that
one of the words that we haven't used
yet that would have been used an awful
lot 10 years ago was alignment problem
so
how relevant is discussing the alignment
problem now uh and I actually before you
even get to that does it look like if
you were to put your money on the table
the
front runner Contender for creating AGI
would it be neural networks can a large
learning model becomes sentient and be
the AGI thing
foreign
there's a big variety of opinions and
um on the one hand people like my friend
Gary Marcus at New York University argue
that large language models just based on
deep learning and just based on neural
networks cannot do
many of the key cognitive tasks that
humans do so can't reach AGI and he's
got various Arguments for that and some
pretty good recent books on AI on the
other hand you have people saying well
people keep underestimating deep
learning and keep on underestimating
what what it can do and as far as we can
see there aren't really very many horrid
constraints
you know against it and moreover
the human brain
looks an awful like an awful lot like a
large neural network like we don't
exactly learn using deep learning
methods as uh you know
GPT does but we're basically just a
bunch of um you know neurons with
connections so what do you what do you
think is it just can we just lay a
transistor upon transistor upon
reinforcement and will we arrive at
something that approaches sentience and
or AGI
foreign
work I did in in neural networks back in
the day was was based on the assumption
that no you can't just train a big
random kind of incoherent formless Blank
Slate neural network to do anything it
needs a bunch of structure it needs an
architecture it might even need an
evolved architecture where you have to
try a bunch of different ways of wiring
up large networks before you can get
something that's really smart
now I'm more humble I don't know you
know I was excited about that because I
studied a lot of evolutionary biology
and animal behavior and it looked like
simple nervous systems often had quite a
bit of architecture to them
you know you look at a bumblebee or an
ant nervous system and it's it's highly
architected it's not just a glob of
neurons there's like ganglia doing
different things there's perceptual
um
clumps of nerve cells doing particular
things but at this point
I don't know like it wouldn't surprise
me that much
if you you know GPT eight or nine
proved to be able to do pretty much
everything that humans can do without
having a whole bunch of intrinsic
structure on the other hand Gary Marcus
might be right
that you actually need a radically
different approach
um I'm not sure it matters all that much
though in terms of the AI safety issues
because one way or another the AI
companies will
figure out how to do AGI if
if we give them the money and the talent
and the resources and the social support
they will figure it out sooner or later
why haven't we talked about the
alignment problem why is that a term
that I'm seeing less of uh as well is it
just that there's so much AI progression
that it's not a problem or is is there a
new issue with regards to this that
neural Nets have created
people are still talking about AI
alignment it's just
um
there's so much more Buzz right now
about you know the amazing new
capabilities not just of the large
language models but also of like
mid-journey and Dolly and the other
generative AI systems for creating
images and videos and the ones that can
create music and amazing audio
um so people are excited about that
people are extra extra alarmed about the
AI risks
and everybody interested in so-called AI
alignment is still trundling along
working on it right I'm still writing
essays about AI alignment
um
it's just gotten slightly overwhelmed by
all the other you know shiny new issues
what is AI alignment for the people who
aren't inducted
the basic notion is how do you get an AI
system to be quote aligned with human
values and preferences and goals
um and it's kind of like the the
so-called principal agent problem in in
companies like if you have a bunch of
investors right and they are supporting
a company and you create like a board of
directors and the board of directors
gives power to a CEO
how do you make sure the interests and
decision making of the CEO are aligned
with those of the board of directors and
in turn with the shareholders right
that's a kind of corporate alignment
problem
um a political alignment problem would
be how do you elect a president that
actually serves the interests of the
voters instead of their own interests
in terms of AI it would be how do you
create an AI system that actually
respects what the uh the human users
want it to do
or kind of what they really wanted to do
even if they can't quite articulate
everything about what they wanted to do
right and there's there's lots and lots
of myths and legends going back
thousands of years about the pitfalls of
getting some power like some Genie that
pops out of a lamp where it says you
know what wishes would you like anything
Midas turns everything into gold right
and you you give it wishes and then it
it interprets what you want sort of over
literally
right in a way that's absolutely
disastrous
so AI alignment in principle is about
making sure the AI is kind of doing what
you want and and even in ways that you
can't necessarily articulate that fit
with
a whole background of like human common
sense and and moral Norms that we might
not even be able to articulate
to the AI system but that we would still
want it to act as if it understands yes
however different individual humans have
got different values and conflict of
interests happen a lot
so which human values should AIS be
aligned with
yeah so this is exactly the issue that
I've I've been writing about in my um
effective altruism Forum essays for the
last year or so
I've pointed out like you can say we
want the AI to just
respect the views of its its end user
the consumer who actually buys it but
what if the end user is a terrorist what
if the end user is a political
propagandist what if the end user is in
a hostile nation state what if they're a
bad actor right do you really want the
AI to do what they want it to do
and second if you try to aggregate like
the collective will of humanity right
where you go well the AGI should sort of
do what
people in general would want it to do if
it could summarize all of our
preferences
well
then you get into interesting issues
like well
men and women have like different
interests so should the AI go with the
50 of people who are male or the 50 who
are female or whatever people have
different political views right
um and in one essay I pointed out eighty
percent of humans are still involved in
organized religion
right and yet the AI industry is
dominated by secular atheists
who largely have contempt for religion
so if you have an AI That's trying to be
aligned with people in general
and people in general have religious
values
that are being completely ignored and
dismissed and mocked
by the AI industry itself
right then how do you actually get
alignment with with people they don't
really mean alignment with what people
believe they kind of sort of mean like
we want the AI to be aligned with what a
good
liberal secular humanist democratic Bay
Area Tech bro
values
right that's really the bottom line
that's that's what AI alignment actually
boils down to in practice
yes that
does it split the difference uh I
remember to not spoil the end of super
intelligence but the like the good guy
that that comes in at the end is machine
extrapolated volition which is uh in a
world in which we can't be sure that
we're going to give a program an
instruction and that program is going to
take the instruction and turn this all
into paper clips or or kill us so it can
make a cup of coffee
telling the machine
do what you think we would have asked
you to do had we have had sufficient
wisdom to ask you to do it that is
roughly machine extrapolated volition
but even that modeling human preferences
needs to be done based on a group of
humans and which preferences do you mean
and when preferences come into conflict
which ones win and if it's 50 50 between
men and women and you split the
difference between the two like is that
optimal is that actually optimal or is
it more optimal to swing it to more
toward one way or another one group
might be incredibly vehement about
something but it might be immoral okay
so given the fact that we've been trying
to work out ethics and virtue and
morality ourselves philosophically for
thousands of years and have made some
progress but not got anything that's too
definitive
please try and put that into code for me
and which which morals do you mean do
you mean the morals of modern secular
21st century Western industrialized
educated people but why why don't we use
the ones from the Roman era or why don't
we say well let's wait for another 3000
years and see what which ones come up
there
yeah and I think there's there's two
additional sort of alignment problems
I've been worried about one is um what
I've called embodied values so when we
think of values and preferences we
typically think of things we can
articulate verbally like if someone says
what do you want for dinner like we have
a verbal answer we can give
but I made the point that like
our brain is only two percent of our
body mass right our body is full of all
these other tissues and organs that have
evolved their own kind of values and
agendas in a way right and like all
these embodied values like what your
immune system really wants to do is
fight off pathogens that might infect
you
so ideally you'd want an AI to be
aligned not just with the values that
our brain can articulate through our
words
but that is also kind of like
biomedically aligned with the interests
of our bodies
right so that we are kept healthy and
well and live a long time
now if you ask people
how do those embodied values actually
work like we have no idea
right we can't even articulate those so
methods for training AI system based on
human verbal feedback
cannot even in principle align with all
these embodied values of our of our
bodies
a second issue is
you know from an evolutionary Viewpoint
the development of AGI would be a major
evolutionary transition it's a big thing
that's comparable to the evolution of
like
um DNA or the evolution of multicellular
life or the evolution of nervous systems
like it's a big deal that doesn't just
affect humans it also affects like the
other 70 000 species of vertebrates and
the other 10 million species of
invertebrates and all the life on the
planet
now if you ask okay how do you align AI
not just with humans
right but all the other kind of organic
stakeholders all the other life forms on
Earth who might be affected by AI
okay how does the AI learn
the true interests of an elephant or a
dolphin or a termite Hive or
you know all the other life forms that
that matter
I've never seen anybody in the AI
industry even sort of seriously talk
about this
and yet they portray AI as this
kind of world historical thing that will
re-engineer the entire uh you know
planetary ecosystem
yeah it could quite quickly become the
most super intelligent powerful Greta
tunberg ever created just screaming from
the top of some transistor Hill I I read
a thing from uh burn Hobart and Tobias
Huber talking about uh AI safetyism
being more of a risk to society than
anything that AI doomers are predicting
why it seems like you've put forward a
case that suggests this is something we
should be concerned about
etc etc what is the other side of the
fence to this what is the side of the
fence that says stop
yourself about safetyism let's
just crack on
foreign
I think if I was going to like um
put forward the best possible case
against myself right the Steel Man the
the anti-ai doomers
I would say something like
um
if you pause
or stop the development of AGI there are
huge potential opportunity costs there
are lots of human problems maybe that AI
could help solve right and the usual
ones that people talk about are oh AGI
can help us like solve climate change it
could help create peace and prosperity
it could reduce global conflict blah
blah
um I do not actually find those very
compelling I think there are often ways
to to solve lots of those problems
without developing AI
the one potential application that does
give me serious pause that I've talked
and thought about a lot is longevity
issues okay if you had an AI that could
seriously help
develop longevity treatments and
anti-aging treatments and help
regenerative medicine research and help
biotech so that we don't all have to die
right I'm 58 I would like not to die I
would like to live another 100 200 years
however long I want to live I would love
to live that long maybe
if we pause AI I don't get that benefit
right
now personally
I'm willing to die for my kids
I'm willing to forego longevity
treatments
if we reduce existential risk
some people might have a different view
some people might be like
well screw you Miller I don't want to
have to die just because you're scared
of AI
I understand that I respect that
Viewpoint let's have that debate let's
talk about it
my personal hunch is that if we invested
as much directly into longevity research
as we're investing in AI
we could actually probably fix aging
within like 20 or 30 years
um but people what's happening instead
as is people are like
we know it's really hard to get people
to directly support longevity treatment
people are in a kind of pro-death Trance
they think it's weird and creepy to head
towards immortality so we know we can't
sell that as a research program
right so instead we're going to sell
them on AI
and then AI will like magically deliver
the anti-aging cures
right I've I've often seen this argument
right people won't directly support
longevity research but AI can solve
longevity so that's why we need AI does
that make sense yeah it does it's um
I don't know I'm really trying to stay
open-minded to this but coming from uh
bostromite background you know I've
always for
nearly a decade now been so
wary and touchy feely about anything
that even looks remotely smart that
comes out of you know Siri Siri was
something that I remember there was a oh
my God like you know is Siri going to be
conscious what sort of problems are
going to because etc etc
but they're definitely there feels a
part of me that's like well look if
you're going to work incredibly hard to
fix longevity problems so that you keep
people alive you keep some people alive
that are alive right now
and the outcome of that is that
everybody is dead within two centuries
that seems like a bad deal it seems like
a relatively pointless deal so we're
talking about terrible outcomes that
could occur
um the tip of the spear or the the top
of the mountain so to speak looking at
some of the stuff that's going to occur
in the interim between now and then you
know because this is
how many transistors is it going to take
will the large learning models get us
there is it GPT 8 is it GPT never
um but some of the things that we
probably can be certain about are what
the tools and the Technologies are
enabling at the moment stuff like
deception deep fakes uh information
sanitization and misinformation
elections politics persuasion friend
Bots loneliness what are you most
concerned about that is very high
likelihood maybe it's already here what
are the things that people should be
looking out for with the rise of AI over
the coming years
okay
I I think the 2024 election cycle in
America is going to be absolutely wild
and shocking and is going to involve a
lot of
narrow AI applications in political
propaganda
and ads and deep fakes and speech
writing and
sort of the mass customization of
political propaganda
um because one thing AIS can do is track
you know individual
preferences and values and priorities
through social media interaction and get
a pretty good model of what every
potential voter really cares about and
then potentially customize political
messaging
directly to each voter in a way that
like pushes their own hot buttons very
effectively right so like if you're a
Democrat and you care a lot about racism
but you don't really care about abortion
then you'll you'll start to see
customized ads that are like very
anti-racist but they don't talk about
abortion
that will be new we haven't seen that
before before political ads were kind of
like lowest common denominator TV spots
or magazine ads that sort of tried to
hit like the the typical
undecided voter
but now I think in 2024 my humble
prediction is we're going to see a lot
more
um narrow AI used for purposes of uh
political manipulation
and I think people will be shocked at
how
effective and persuasive it is
and I have no idea what the outcome of
the election will be but I think the
outcome for a lot of Voters will be to
go
oh my God we we like don't have a sort
of political immune system that can
fight this
very well does that mean that AI at the
moment has got theory of mind
so theory of mind is like your ability
to understand the beliefs and
preferences of others
I think large language models do have
pragmatically speaking theory of mind
and that they have absorbed
you know all the lessons that are
available from the internet about how to
understand people's beliefs and desires
so I think if you ask
uh like a GPT
can you please write really good ad copy
to advertise particular good or service
it's pretty good at that like I know
people in advertising who are like oh my
God GPT is better
at ads then then we are and so we have
to use it because our Rivals are using
it and I think that also applies to
political political ads and speech
writing
yes a functionally it is able to achieve
the same thing as somebody that has
theory of mind and this comes back to
you know a conversation that everyone is
having which is when do you know if
something is conscious or not you know
it
um touring test
turned out to kind of be a bit of a
uh insufficient uh barometer for working
out whether or not something is
sufficiently intelligent because there's
no way that you can speak to a
well-trained chat gbt model and not
think that there is something inside of
that but you don't know if there is any
there there right is this just a p
zombie is it just making all of the
movements and the sounds and the shakes
and you roll this forward into a
sufficiently fleshy sufficiently pink
sufficiently right proportioned robot
that can move around your house and you
go that's a human that's a human I know
it's a human it looks like a human it
walks and talks like a human
so
at the moment yeah that the function and
the outcome that these things are able
to achieve is so close to somebody that
is able to do that so 2024 election lots
of persuasion lots of speech writing
um what about social media and the News
landscape and the information landscape
and and people
um both producing and consuming content
you know we're coming we're still in
this world of content creators at the
moment how do you think that that's
going to be influenced
you know I think what we've got at the
moment is
well you know Noam Chomsky wrote this
book 30 years ago about you know uh
manufacturing consent about the way that
in in so-called Democratic societies
the way that power actually works is
through
subtle
semi-voluntary propaganda right people
are willing to go to school to absorb
the indoctrination that we get in public
schools and we expose ourselves
voluntarily to certain kinds of
newspapers and magazines and TV news
shows and then they sort of guide us
into what we should think and value and
the engineering of all of that
has been done before by humans by people
who do
um uh who are Hollywood screenwriters
and political speechwriters and uh ad
people marketing people public relations
people right there are millions of
humans involved in that Venture of
trying to manipulate public opinion
in various directions but now they're
going to have these AI systems
that hugely increase
their reach their ability to customize
messages to particular individuals their
ability to kind of capitalize on Big
Data gathered through social media
that can do extremely fast
iterative testing of messaging right not
just split tests or just focus groups
like in traditional marketing but that
do the kind of things that Facebook does
in terms of testing all the time which
of millions of ads are most effective
so we're going to have kind of this
um AI powered like hegemony Warfare like
worldview Warfare where people are
advocating their uh political
ideological religious belief systems and
they're fighting against
enemies right and there's going to be a
massive
kind of ongoing culture War which in a
way is the only war that matters anymore
um but it's going to be heavily heavily
shaped increasingly by AI tools
what about friend Bots and people who
just abscond the real world for some
virtual best mate or a girlfriend or
whatever in their apartment do you think
that this is something that's likely
yeah absolutely this this is something I
wrote about and in my most uh recent
essay on uh anti
a likely anti-ai backlash one thing that
will provoke I think a backlash is
um
people using AI
as fake boyfriends girlfriends and
Friends
and getting a kind of
um pseudo-intimacy
and sort of validation from AI systems
and you might think oh surely people
can't be that gullible that they would
prefer interacting with just a smart
chat bot but if you think like we're
talking about a chatbot that could
potentially remember every single
personal detail about you
that remembers all previous
conversations with you that can try out
different ways of interacting with you
to see what you like and what you don't
like that is much more attentive
than any real-life boyfriend or
girlfriend that has infinite patience
for listening to all your and all
your dumb stories and all your neurotic
woes right in a way that no living lover
would ever put up with
and it would be like the perfect
um you know combination psychotherapist
and friend and girlfriend and and mentor
and Confidant and and all of that and
we're pretty close to being being able
to do that
so I do worry that
real life social interaction will look
like a pretty
poor substitute
for those kinds of AI Pals why would
that close why would that cause a
backlash
I think it'll be a backlash because
people who don't get caught up in having
an AI boyfriend or girlfriend will look
at the people who are caught up in it
like gen Z staying alone in their
apartments and never going out on dates
and not getting married and not
reproducing and they might go oh my God
this is the most socially toxic
technology ever invented
like the birth rate is dropping nobody's
dating nobody's having real
relationships this is not sustainable
and therefore we are going to do a moral
backlash or religious backlash or
political backlash that says
this is not the way we want civilization
to go
I saw an a headline which you'll have
seen fifty percent of AI researchers
believe that there is a 10 or greater
risk that humans go extinct due to our
inability to control Ai and the center
for AI safety had a ton of researchers
agree with the statement mitigating the
risks of Extinction from AI should be a
global priority alongside other societal
scale risks such as pandemics nuclear
war the open letter has been signed by
more than 350 Executives researchers and
Engineers working in AI plus Elon Musk
as well was a part of this movement
how effective are AI experts are
predicting this AI development and the
risks moving forward and if 50 of the
people say that there is a 10 chance
that the technology they're working on
is going to end us
what happens next that it is there are
there going to be picket lines of
disgruntled terrified AI researchers
outside of openai's lab what's happening
yeah I mean there is a movement actually
to do literal uh protests and
demonstrations and and picket lines I'm
involved in a in a slack group that uh
you know some members of that are
actually organizing like
uh pickets in front of open AI or in
front of deepmind in London
um
now of course the point of these letters
and I think I've signed all the letters
that are going around myself
we know the letters themselves will not
stop the AI industry from doing what
it's doing however the whole point of
the letters is to draw public attention
to the issue right to get uh press
coverage to get the general public
thinking about these things you know
hopefully tuning into like podcasts like
this and reading the books they need to
read and becoming
uh
politically motivated to take this
seriously as as an issue
and I think in that regard uh the
letters have been
surprisingly effective like the amount
of press coverage
given to AI risk in the last couple
months is hugely greater than anything
in like the previous 10 years
and the government response like you
know Biden inviting AI industry
Executives to the White House and prime
minister Britain taking this very
seriously and tweeting about it and
having like AI safety Summits in London
uh there's a lot of public support
for
slowing down and the AI industry being
held accountable and people asking hard
questions about like what exactly is the
end game here
like mass unemployment and then
Extinction is that really the direction
we want to go in
um
and I think you know the AI experts
themselves
I hope have a new humility about their
ability to predict things because
they'll know they've been blindsided by
GPT they they didn't expect these kind
of capabilities this quickly
so when certain AI researchers like
let's say law yon lacun who makes fun of
AI doomers a lot on Twitter
hopefully people like him will stay
open-minded enough that they might
actually kind of re-examine their biases
and maybe it'll have a kind of Jeff
Hinton moment right like leading our
researcher Jeff Hinton going at age 75
oh no
oh no I think my life's work might have
been really actually kinda evil and
imposing risks on people and I'm going
to resign from Google and blow the
whistle and make a big fuss about this
yeah there was a tweet as well from Tim
Urban that you responded to Tim said
whether you're optimistic or pessimistic
about the future the fact is that we're
facing an existential risk at worst and
a vastly different future world at best
the world that we're used to very well
may not be around for much longer so
let's really enjoy the world that we
have it visit the places you've always
wanted to visit dive into that hobby
you've always wanted to try spend
quality time with your loved ones Savor
each Sunny Saturday it's great mail each
moment of fun if we end up looking back
on these days with great Nostalgia we
want to at least know we made the most
of the time that we had and you
responded and said existential risk
isn't anywhere near the worst thing that
we could have there's something called s
risk as well above and beyond x risk
what's asterisk
s risk is suffering risk so
with Extinction right everybody's dead
and then they don't experience anything
anymore and that's like pretty bad
compared to experiencing things and
being happy but
as anybody who's ever suffered chronic
pain or torture will will attest like
there are things worse than death there
are levels of suffering that could
potentially be imposed by new
technologies that would make us wish
we had gone extinct
I personally haven't
taken s risk that seriously I don't know
that much about it there's other people
are more expert on it than me I've only
read like a few science fiction novels
that depict
like really really bad s risks that
could be imposed there's a there's a
novel called surface detail by e m Banks
where long story short
in the far future some religious
fundamentalists decide Heaven and Hell
don't really exist but we should make
them exist so we're going to upload
everybody's Brain before they die into a
simulated reality and if we think
they've been bad and naughty we're going
to make them live in a simulated virtual
hell for like subjective Millennia and
like thousands of years of suffering and
torture and Mayhem and death
and like that would be worse than being
dead forever
so that's risk
um some people worry a lot about it
um I haven't really
focused on it very much but I think when
people like Tim Urban say yeah it'll
either be great or we'll all be dead so
just
smell the daffodils and enjoy your steak
and and
visit beautiful Austin Texas or whatever
whatever they think we should be doing
I think no that like
I want my daughters to grow up
being very confident that a they won't
suffer an Extinction risk and and B they
won't suffer you know an S risk
yeah the take it a little bit more
seriously one final person who waited in
was Mark Andreessen I'm going to guess
that you read his big essay why AI will
save the world recently what were your
thoughts on that
you know I used to have so much respect
for Andreessen
and I think he's just so
witlessly stupid about the extinction
risks
regarding it truly
baffles me like how you can have a brain
that big
and be so
honestly I think what what happens with
a lot of these sort of
well-respected Rich Elders like lacoon
or andreasen is
like they've had a great career they've
done well in business they've you know
made a bunch of money
they are technically Savvy I have I have
no doubts they're they have high IQs but
I think they radically overestimate
their ability to understand issues that
they just haven't read very much about
and I think if you haven't read you know
Nick boss from superintelligence you
haven't read Toby Awards the precipice
you haven't read some of the other key
ideas if you haven't read Alias or
utkowski's work then
like you're just going to be Reinventing
a bunch of very amateurish objections
to that kind of work that like we're
already addressed 10 or 20 years ago
by the actual experts who've been
thinking about this
so this is one of those topics where
it's very important not to just defer to
people because they're rich or famous or
smart like you really want to dive deep
on have they thought through these
issues have they engaged in meaningful
conversations with other experts in the
area and if they haven't
they probably do not know what they're
talking about
what would you do if you could step in
what would your prescription or policy
be if you had a omnipotent omniscient
God's eye view
I think I would love for the General
Public
just to tune into the issue
to apply their natural
survival instincts and their parental
instincts to go wow this looks like a
threat to me my family my kids my
grandkids this is a legit threat I
should take it just as seriously as I
would take a local crime wave or just as
seriously as people took nuclear war
back in the Cold War
and this is a matter of potentially life
and death you know for me and my family
I want them to personalize it I don't
want them to just think this is some
abstract science fiction scenario that
is in like the distant future
this is the stuff that like could affect
you know
my 26 year old daughter or my 15 month
old daughter or like my actual kids and
cousins and nieces and nephews and
whatever
and once you take it seriously then
you're motivated to learn more
and to start moralizing the issue and to
go
are the people who are charging headlong
into this
right through some combination of like
greed and hubris and Prestige and
whatever are they on our side are they
pro-human are they fighting for my
family or are they just
caught up in some kind of um
sort of delusional project
that is at heart Reckless and evil and
then what
and then if they decide this is reckless
and evil let's let's effing morally
stigmatize it let's say if you work in
the AI industry
and you are not spending most of your
time worried about AI safety
then you're a bad person and I don't
want to associate with you I don't want
to date you I don't want to be your
friend I don't want to invest with you I
don't want to supply you with Hardware
or software or anything else
um I don't want you to be a block rate
in our city-state or country
and I want to uh
you know shut it down now I'm not
advocating for like a violent so-called
like but Larry and Jihad where people
rise up and they're like smash all the
machines and kill all the air like no I
don't want that
um mostly because it would be
counterproductive
in terms of PR like violence doesn't
work in the social media era it's just
delegitimizes your cause
um but I think short of violence it's
important to
uh be aware that like we can use all the
techniques of persuasion and activism in
this domain
that people used in
every other social movement that we're
familiar with civil rights movement the
gay rights movement
um you know the libertarian movement uh
crypto like anything that's been at all
successful in terms of the public rising
up and saying we want a change of values
uh
we can use all that in fighting Reckless
AI development
I suppose the Challenger game that you
have is everyone is being distracted
into a beautiful
field with daisies growing in it and
free cake recipes and essays written for
them for school and University so yeah I
I worry that the
the novelty and the immediate
convenience that's been afforded by
these new advances is causing it to seem
both so
benign
and enjoyable and distracting and
entertaining
that galvanizing people to see this is
going and presumably this is the one of
the primary challenges that you're
facing
I think what what I would say to people
is like you can kind of have your cake
and eat it too in terms of
like there's a whole range of incredible
software
and narrow AI That's that's absolutely
wonderful like if you look at the
progress in computer graphics and
Hollywood movies it's amazing like I
love Avengers movies and a lot of that
would be considered
very Advanced generative AI
right by the standards of the 1970s
right the fact that many modern uh
movies are largely
kind of AI graphic generated
that that's pretty cool the fact that
you know Google Maps can actually get
you from A to B
pretty reliably and taking into account
like traffic that is narrow AI That's a
huge benefit to many people
and there are probably hundreds of cases
where you can have
quite safe narrow AI applications that
deliver huge quality life benefits to
people
but you don't have to go down the road
towards AGI
right or towards other kinds of Highly
risky narrow AI
and even in longevity
research like you could have narrow AI
that does biomedical research and
synthesizes scientific literatures about
which molecules might be helpful and
that maybe even can help you run larger
scale longevity studies
right and maybe we can get longevity
through that without having to go down
the road of extremely dangerous AGI
Jeffrey Miller ladies and gentlemen if
people want to keep up to date with the
work that you're doing whether it be
evolutionary psychology or AI risk where
should they go
they can go to my website primalpali.com
and they can also see my essays on the
effective altruism Forum which is EA
Forum where I I publish quite a bit
these days Jeffrey I appreciate you I'm
looking forward to seeing what we get to
talk about next time as well my pleasure
Chris thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe